right liberal climate alarmists are at
it again forget about isis and communist
china democrats now say climate change
is the largest national security threat
facing our nation
the bottom line is that the democratic
party in the house democratic caucus
is the party of national security in the
21st century
we are the party that's dedicated to
rule of law
to affirming our connection with our
allies
to addressing the largest national
security threat facing our planet in our
country that is climate change which is
both
a threat multiplier and a threat
magnifier
and dedicated to doing this in the right
way all right and the liberal media is
wagging their finger at moderate
democrats who refused to support biden's
radical green agenda a washington post
reporter claims that senator joe manchin
delaying biden's climate bill could have
fatal permanent and global repercussions
meanwhile climate protesters putting the
brakes on tour de france by chaining
themselves together and blocking the
roadway officials were forced to
physically drag the activists away
now a part of me wants to talk to greg
first but i'm not going to talk to you
first bro why what did i do no because i
could feel that you were laughing about
them being dragged away but the first
thing i want to go to is i want to go to
you katie i want to go to this whole
thing about the democrats or the party
that are aligned with the right you may
be curious to address the national
security threat facing the largest
national security threat facing our
planet which is climate change i'm not
even going to ask you about the rule of
law thing but how is this a national
security threat
climate change and it's an excuse to
scare people into getting on board with
all these proposals uh if any person in
congress who believes that climate
change is the largest national security
threat to this country shouldn't be in
congress because they're not doing their
job to protect the country china is the
biggest national security threat to this
country and the green green i say green
because it's not really actually
actually green environmentalist agenda
which is extreme emboldens china it
allows us to buy more solar panels from
china it allows us to import them
because we can't build them here due to
a lot of our environmental regulations
like what you said earlier about we're
allowed to be morally superior here and
have you know clean green air but we're
fine with having you know china china
have dirty polluted air um it's a
national security threat for the country
for the left to be pushing this agenda
which is going to cause an energy crisis
here at home but also we're seeing it in
europe and more importantly it's going
to cause a lot of human pain and
suffering so when joe biden was in
europe two weeks ago and boris johnson
the uk prime minister proposed that as
we're seeing the shortage of food and
wheat across the world that maybe we
should just temporarily turn over some
of these biofuel fields that we're using
for green proposals to be used for food
for human beings for just a little bit
you know a little while joe biden said
no so they are willing to allow human
beings to suffer and to starve for the
sake of their agenda well at the same
time the very people pushing this agenda
don't live by their own rules
and you know jesse he said that we
americans we agreed to suffer and pay
higher gas prices too during the ukraine
war because we want democracy over there
i don't know do we now
with gas prices the way they are i think
i think in the mid in the beginning
everyone was like oh ukraine and now
everyone's like what's going on in
ukraine people totally forgot about
ukraine
that congressman was weird did you guys
listen no it's it's true geraldo this
war in ukraine could last
five years seven years and biden's gonna
still say oh we have to suffer for
ukraine do you remember somebody
saying this maybe four months ago and
getting a lot of grief seriously katie
that was really poignant
i know it's a great point like always
listen and what are they doing now in
the streets are they are they knifing
car tires that is the last thing you
want to do to convince anybody
climate action the climate activists not
the ukrainians
if those ukrainians
jab some more blades into those russian
tanks that'll change the tide of the war
all right geraldo talk to me about these
climate activists they're not happy with
biden they're really unhappy with them i
i have a slightly different take because
i do believe
that the world is warming i think that i
think we can all agree whether it's
natural causes or accelerated by
man-made activity i don't know why i do
know that we are facing
several existential crises uh not the
least of which is inflation uh it is
time to deal with that emergency it is
right the inflation right the people
have to eat you don't starve people as a
way to reform the climate
to to save the planet you don't make
people die to reduce the population so i
just think that it's a question of
priorities and it just it's it is
climate change is not the most emergent
issue all right geraldo speaks finally
the reason i wanted to go to you first
was do you remember last time i don't
know if it was was it one of the
starbucks where they they were gluing
their hands to the counter and you you
made some funny jokes about the fact
that you know what makes people think
that you know that we're going to side
with them because they're gluing their
hands and interrupting the flow of
coffee drinkers
and these people chain themselves to the
roads or whatever yeah do you see what
the italians do they pick them up and
throw them away i love that i don't
believe that china is the biggest threat
to america i believe america is the
biggest threat to america when you see
to haraldo's point the our priorities
are so skewed that we're willing to like
basically un-free this country uh make
the blue-collar workers and the
blue-collar voters suffer i think this
is also why democrats are losing the
blue-collar vote is because they're
championing these abstract issues in a
very foolish manner while making the
lives of regular people miserable so
it's not just the vandalism but it's
also the no drilling the shutting down
of gas stations in california the
banning of gas mowers uh the demand to
embrace expensive electric cars that
require batteries that require digging
using gas machines for their little
batteries
the legal question i have for you is
if you find somebody violating your
private stuff like shivving your tires
can you beat their ass to a pulp is
there a legal like seriously to a pulp
yeah if no one's around
let's say they go that was a joke put
the camera on me put the camera on me
that was a joke but you know the thing
is there should be a risk make it into a
game okay you guys want to try to do
this no if you're going to do this we
have a free punch rule so if we find you
we get to punch your lights out then
it's kind of fun there's some places
they wouldn't do it for the purposes of
yeah feeling afraid of the rubicon and
what is punching your lights out what
exactly is that you would say
unconscious conscious good all right let
that go i went on brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now